So now we come back to our original parallel program and the parallel program is
making normal data accesses and synchronization accesses.
There are different threads running on all these
processors. They're all making these normal data
accesses and synchronization accesses. And if the underlying
memory model is an RC memory model, it
distinguishes between normal data accesses and synchronization accesses.
And it knows that if there are normal read/write data accesses, it doesn't have
to do anything in terms of blocking
the processes. It may start initiating coherence actions
corresponding to these data accesses, but it
won't block the processor for coherence actions
to be complete until it encounters a
synchronization operation, which is of the release category.
If a synchronization operation which is a release
operation hits this RC memory model, it's going
to say, ah-ha. In that case all the
data accesses that I've seen from this guy, I
want to make sure that they're all complete
globally, communicated to all the processors. It's going to
ensure that before allowing the synchronization operation to
complete. So the coherence action is only when the
lock is released.